was geht hier vor max und herzlich
willkommen zum heutigen video zusammen
mit escape oder so wir kneten heute
wieder gab es schon gesehen youtuber
kneten ist wieder angesagt jetzt 8 oder
vorschläge geschickt und wir haben dafür
jeweils eine 1 2 1
die lobbys da müssen wir schon mal zwei
stück nähten als auch bei den beiden in
einer minute nicht so kratzer
erkennungsmerkmal wien apa red oder so
dem roten lager gezeigt
also meine leute zeit ist abgelaufen
offiziell also wir haben ja einmal
hitler die verdächtigen hitler dessen
aha ich bin nicht mehr ganz so fest her
aber läuft die lobby ist doch bekannt
dass einer nur einen punkt für nase und
ohren augen im gesicht oder andere hat
halt ein bisschen weiter aufgelegt
gerade aber mein vorteil ist eindeutig
im vergleich zu dir
ich habe die loches und nicht den lacher
weise zwillinge und ich hab zwei gemacht
und trading sind glaube ich
normalerweise 2 nein die hatte
geschrieben die lobby das soll nur einer
sein alter aufgabenstellung verfehlt
aber die kommen hier ohne witz ich habe
mir dafür gewöhnen
über super league klub gebe auf jeden
fall sehr viel zeit bei den gesichts
details gelassen
du bist ja es ist aber ein ja und es ist
ja erhebliche unterschiede
ihr entscheidet wie auch beim letzten
mal mit luca zusammen wer gewonnen hat
also schreibt das wieder in die
kommentare schreibt der nummer eins max
bahr war so ihr wärt ihr habt das jetzt
mal schon gut hinbekommt dann würde ich
sagen
beginnen wir mit runde numero dort ich
bin nur noch 3 2 1 katja magneten
eine minute ist fathi wenig leute dann
bin ich da wo es gebe immer mal die
auswertung
man erkennt sechs typische merkmal hat
er ihr gesicht ist eine wette wer gut
getroffen weil die latte getroffen
das erkennt man oft also leute man will
auf jeden fall erkennen dass sie auch im
handel auch wenn man das so macht das
ist leute gebt euch das hier ist meine
katja also wir haben hier auch die
wesentlichen erkennungsmerkmale
abgebildet einfach so ein komplett
glattes gesicht
ich mach dein gesicht mal nach
mittelschwerer und für einen ewf ist in
ordnung ich glaube wirklich schwierig
für euch zuschauer zu entscheiden wer
denn jetzt tatsächlich gewonnen hat weil
wir nämlich weiter zu schlecht sind um
zu gewinnen aber wir nehmen es zur
nächsten youtuber raus so leute wir
beginnen in 321 kreditmenge mit seinem
red ok als du liest
30 grundschulen alter meister diese
kennt diese komischen figuren ist früher
bei super rtl group legen die kleinen
dicken das ist aber auch aus wie sie
trotzdem happy meal genau wie genau die
genau die technik gewisse ähnlichkeit
genau diese dinger leute damals nämlich
erinnert aber es geht auch aus einem
eimer oder wie ein exotisches pokémon
ein bisschen wie kokowääh wenn man
möchte
das ist mein versuch ein bisschen
fantasie aus bisschen dragonball mäßig
goalie ronnie hier ist mein camp ich
habe sogar noch augen probiert also das
geht ein bisschen unter weil die leicht
deplatziert sind aber hier sind zwei
augen dran
die haare also wirklich ausgelastet
werden noch schneller als in stücke
geschnitten aber dadurch dass so viel
grün gewählt hast ist das serum geht
muss ich sie ja ich weiß dass jeder
kunde wird weil ich dachte rot grün ist
umgedreht nicht die vgf zusammen
kurzum gedichte zeit so leute das war es
auch vom heutigen video ich hoffe
meisterlich gefallen
falls ihr noch mal einen youtuber kneten
partei sehen wollt irgendwie wenn ich
mit luca und sebastian zusammen im oder
bin dann können wir so ein mega youtube
magnet machen dann lasst mal fünf
millionen likes bis zum nächsten mal
schätzen